Good evening, everybody, and
welcome to the second concert
of our 2017-2018
season here in MIT.
So glad to see you
all this evening.
I notice an extra
layer of clothing
on everybody, especially me.
I almost wore my coat for
the performance here tonight.
That's very, very cold
out there tonight.
Jean Sibelius and
Johannes Brahms--
though both of them wrote in
many, many different forms,
they are, without question, two
of our greatest symphonists.
They lived in a time where they
were going against the stream.
Sibelius in the 1920s--
lots of atonal music
is around and about.
The Rite of Spring is
10 years old by the time
this symphony was
written and performed.
But Sibelius's music sounds as
if it's been around forever.
Brahms, of course, is still well
under the shadow of Beethoven,
as he liked to say,
over and over again,
writing very classically
with very great attention
to form and with a
classical-sized orchestra
for the most part, in a time
where Wagner and Mahler is
about to write music that
expands the orchestra
to a great degree.
But here, for mostly, that's
where the similarities end.
Both of them dealt with
personal issues and in a way--
doesn't show up in their
music at least on the surface.
Brahms, by his growing up
poor and his initial work
in a bordello-- that was his
very first job as a pianist--
suffered great abuse
emotionally and spiritually,
without getting into great
detail, from this experience.
And it would be something that
would haunt his relationships,
especially his
relationships with women
for the rest of his life.
Jean Sibelius, very much
in the spirit of Mozart,
had trouble with money, had
trouble dealing with money,
had trouble keeping
money, and also
dealt severely with alcoholism.
And this was something that
would affect his marriage
to greater or lesser degrees for
the entirety of his marriage.
The symphonies, on the surface,
both look very classical.
They're four-movement entities,
and in Brahms's the symphony
especially, you can see very
clear-cut allegro movement
with an intro, a
slow movement, what
seems like it's going to be
a scherzo movement, and then
a large finale very much
in the line of Beethoven.
Sibelius the same-- it
looks allegro on the page.
We have an allegro.
We have something that's
not quite a slow movement
and then a scherzo and
then a large-scale finale.
But they both
depart from the norm
in very, very interesting ways.
Brahms is pushing the
envelope harmonically
and also rhythmically.
For those that are going
to be hearing this piece
for the first time tonight, how
many of you, by show of hands,
will be hearing Brahms 1
for the first time tonight?
Awesome, awesome.
Remember, somebody is always
hearing it for the first time.
This is a great reminder
for orchestras, too, right?
You're going to hear a lot
of syncopation in this piece,
now, not in a Duke
Ellington kind of way,
but Brahms is going to
make you think something
is 1 when it's actually 2.
Or it might actually be
the middle of the bar.
He's always throwing you
off just a little bit.
And in the orchestra,
the layering of rhythm,
the 3 against 2
against 4 going on,
is prevalent throughout
much of this piece,
and it was very daring for
its time, as conservative
as it seems to us now in
the post-jazz era, right?
Harmonically, it lives.
It descends from
Beethoven for sure.
It has hints of Wagner
about it, but it
doesn't push us to any
kind of new world, right?
The Sibelius is very
striking in the sense
that when you hear the piece,
especially its opening,
it sounds like this is
music that has been around
since before Gregorian
chant, and that
is because instead of working
with the normal major-minor
idea, our typical Western
tonality, major-minor,
he's working modally.
In fact, one might
even go so far
as to say the main melody
of the whole symphony
is (SINGING) D, E, F,
G, A, the first five
notes of a minor scale.
And to that, for
expressive purposes,
he tacks on (SINGING) B
natural, C at the end of it.
And if you think about
that in your brain,
and you know where
that sits on the piano,
it's all the white keys if
you go from D to D, right?
So it's modal.
It's the Dorian scale.
And what gives this
piece it's archaic sound
is this reliance on the
modal, and in some ways,
this is not a new
thing to its time.
Certainly, Vaughan
Williams and Holst
are experimenting with
modality over in the UK.
But for continental Europe, this
would have been very striking
in 1923 when we think
about Stravinsky,
Schoenberg, Hindemith, Bartok.
All of these people are on
the scene, and for something
to sound, at least on the
surface, so very simple,
so very motet-like, this
piece, was really striking.
And so they share that,
being progressive while
seeming very conservative
in their time.
And I think the
farther and farther
along we get into the future,
the more both of these pieces
and both of these composers
seem even more daring,
year after year after year.
As is typically
our form, I'm not
going to talk again between
the pieces, so you're welcome.
But my hope for you is,
especially for the Sibelius--
which we are on the
Sixth Symphony now.
The MIT Symphony has
been participating
with the Brookline Symphony
in a chronological cycle
of the Sibelius
seven symphonies,
and so we're almost there.
And I think what
you're going to hear,
especially in this orchestra, is
that they play Sibelius really
well, and it sits well in them.
And the beauty and
voluptuousness of this music,
in a way, bespeaks
the difficulty of it.
You're going to see them working
very hard up here on this piece
but playing it very, very well.
The same with the Brahms-- it's
a notoriously difficult piece.
He's a notoriously difficult
composer to perform.
But the structure of it
is very easy to ascertain,
and there's no question
that this is still
music that moves us, that
hits us to some degree,
no matter how ancient
it may be, right?
The Brahms is almost
50 years younger.
Excuse me.
It's almost 50 years
older than the Sibelius,
so keep that in mind as you
listen to both of these pieces
tonight.
We hope you enjoy them.
I kindly ask out of respect
for the performers that
put an hour after
hour after hour
to present these pieces to
you that you please turn off
all the electronics tonight.
Plus, they're not period.
They weren't around
in 1876 nor 1923,
so we can be part of a
performance practice tonight.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Have a happy Thanksgiving,
and safe travel if you do.
Enjoy
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC - JEAN
SIBELIUS, "SYMPHONY NO.
6 IN D MINOR, OP.
104"]
[APPLAUSE]